" Bonjour. Je m’appelle Greta Thunberg
et merci pour l’invitation. "
L’été 2019 c’est une tournée
européenne pour Greta Thunberg
et elle vient aussi à Paris
à l’initiative d’un député
qui est Matthieu Orphelin
et alors là je me dis
qu’il y a peut-être un coup à jouer.
C’est à l’Assemblée nationale,
chez nous…
Je contacte directement
Matthieu Orphelin.
Ce que je lui explique,
c’est que nous on a du temps
et ce ne sera pas simplement
5 minutes de Greta Thunberg.
Et c’est ce deal qui s’opère
à savoir
on va faire cette captation et
on va fournir le flux pour les autres chaînes
et on ne va pas se mentir,
c’est grisant pour LCP d’être en exclu
et d’avoir ce temps d’avance
sur les chaînes d’info en continu.
" L’icône de la grève pour le climat
arrive à l’Assemblée nationale.
La suédoise,
Greta Thunberg
est accueillie par Matthieu Orphelin
le député écologiste qui l’a invitée. "
Ceux qui sont venus
l’accueillent plutôt bien.
Ceux qui ne veulent pas
boycottent en fait
et ils le disent largement
sur les réseaux sociaux le jour J.
Les tweets sont très violents.
C’est: «On n’a pas besoin
de prêtresse en culottes courtes»…
Elle suscite encore de l’hystérie
des comportements qui
ne sont pas tellement rationnels
mais c’est vraiment le rôle de LCP
à un moment donné de se dire
on a vraiment une discussion
qui peut se nouer sur un dialogue citoyen
avec des parlementaires
sur la question de l’écologie
et de la transition énergétique.
" Ce n’est pas grave.
Après tout nous ne sommes
jamais que des enfants.
Vous n’avez pas
le devoir de nous écouter
par contre vous avez
le devoir d’écouter les scientifiques. "
Ceux qui sont venus l’écouter
sont plutôt attentifs, intéressés
voire vont féliciter
Greta Thunberg.
Et une fois de plus, la réponse
de Greta Thunberg est assez cash.
Elle n’est pas là pour séduire
elle est là pour donner
son message d’alerte
un message assez abrupt.
" J’ai entendu beaucoup
de gens qui disent:
merci, vous me donnez
de l’espoir pour l’avenir.
J’ai l’impression que vous n’avez pas
bien compris ce que nous disons.
Donc plutôt que de louer
ce que nous faisons
essayez, vous,
de faire quelque chose. "
Quand ça part sur
les réseaux sociaux qui sont
avec des communautés
très larges
c’est repris par
de multiples personnes.
Ça a été le cas même
aux Etats-Unis
d’Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez
qui reprend le tweet
donc le tweet LCP voyage
un petit peu partout dans le monde
et ça permet un tour du monde
du logo LCP grâce à ces images.
" Et c’est tout ce
que nous vous demandons:
unissez-vous derrière
les scientifiques! Merci. "
Quand on arrive à avoir en exclu
et en direct ce genre d’évènement
c’est bon pour l’audience,
mais c’est plus largement que ça
c’est plus de visibilité
pour la chaîne et ça la situe
lorsqu’il y a des
événements à l’Assemblée
comme une chaîne incontournable.